what's up guys we're here with some
Starfire gameplay from injustice to
right from nether realms livestream
we've got showcases for all the other
characters too so check those out if you
haven't already and be sure to like and
subscribe to keep up with all the DLC
fighters coming to the game alright
alright so Starfire is meant to be a
beginner friendly character she's very
straightforward easy to pick up has kind
of a smaller moveset she's there's
there's not a lot of complex stuff if
you're a fan of Teen Titans and you're
like you know I'm not a great fighting
game player I want an easy character to
play she is your girl you're gonna have
a lot of fun but she does have a few
little intricacies that if you're a
hardcore player you're gonna get into so
let's start with the normal attacks
normals her buddies her buttons one of
her key moves is her for two which is a
high attack but it has a ton of range
and it's relatively quick and she has a
couple options she has four two one plus
three which is a throw and that'll throw
them the opposite way it will not come
out on with or block but then she has
four two two which ends in a quick
overhead nice so the idea here is if the
opponent's just ducking and they're
waiting to like blow up but with four -
you can do four to two and it's gonna
hit him really quickly so this is kind
of like her main rid mate mid mid range
moves you can see her walk speed is not
the fastest so it's more so this is kind
of one of remained mobility tools in
addition to - so she also has her one
one three which is like her combo ender
she can do a special move and it's just
kind of a standard jab she has um this
is my favorite standing - and then she
has a couple options it's a fast mid and
then she can go into the slow and it has
to complete under it's safe on block and
it looks awesome and then she has to 3
which is multi hitting or move can you
hold that you cannot hold it actually
just does it automatically hold that and
unblocked it's safe and it's also like
the best hit confirm move ever
and you can hinder it you can end it in
that safe so you have all kind of
shenanigans you could do I want to say
something real quickly and that someone
on stream said when you said to the
beginner-friendly character they said
that a flashy combos are out the window
though I don't know about that yeah boo
sorry I love doing them they're just
easy to do so like you could do this
into some of her special moves we'll
talk about later or you can just end the
string and if it happens to hit you can
go into a combo which will show later
and then lastly she has back one which
is her low she can combo into it or she
can do the full string which actually
has a ton of rain got a little oh that
is a low low now she's not really a low
overhead character she doesn't have like
a really fast overhead that can pop you
up so she does have this low option but
she does have extremely good back three
and four through her back three guys a
ton of range you can see here it goes
really really really far I love using it
great looking I mean the effects on
Starfire I absolutely I love her effects
and her for three is super cool again
tons of range and it's actually this
beam that hits the ground
yeah you always think it's a low even
though it's a four three yeah you know
it makes you think that I agree with you
her down to uses our beam it's excellent
and so does our down three now her down
three got something interesting about it
it's this is already good like this is
one of the longest shrinking sweeps but
she has an extra version which is more
punishable but actually hits farther
along here you could see it goes against
the ground how's it done that's done by
holding down forward and hitting three
instead of just down see your tweet it's
like it's a Grodd secret sweet yeah so
the trade-off is it's more easier to
punish but it has a lot more range and
then her jump attacks have something
similar this is her normal jump three
which is already very good it's this
beam it's really good for cross ups but
she also has an extended version where
the beam actually goes down and touches
the ground so the trade-off here is you
can't tune one into it and it's more
punishable on block but I will actually
have like twice as much range and then
from there you see how she's twisting in
the air you can actually do the other
way and she twist the other way and you
can do the long range one like that too
just she has four different jump threes
that
like really good cross-ups so to me
that's one of her main bits of tools
where she lacks and like an overhead low
mix up she excels in these jump attack
mix ups and I think it's gonna
complement her ground game that we're
gonna cover pretty soon go Hassan let's
also see your throat I love I love
throws that use like vertical space yes
like the relaxed use for my favorite was
rough you know I want her flaming here -
yeah I absolutely love her here so let's
go over special moves nailed it
she has a standard projectile that's
very good it's a high but it does good
damage and it's very very fast it
recovers very fast so you kind of use
this move to kind of control space get
them to slow down and that allows her to
walk in or - up and this is gonna be
complemented by all of our other special
moves she didn't have these cluster
bombs you do down back one and you can
actually choose close medium far or very
far now these things are really good on
block really good on hit they're
multiple hits and when the opponent
blocks it's gonna kind of stuff the rest
of her zoning game they do good ship
they're a really really great space
control tool the thing is they don't
track so you have to guess close medium
far very far so that means if the
opponent thinks you're gonna do like
very far they can go ahead and dash in
but obviously we just showed you she has
a good fireball so dashing in is
dangerous oh I also forgot the meter
burn in this super garage and yeah she
could do this in the air too and it's a
barrage now the meter burn of the
cluster bomb is very interesting it's
basically its own moon she sets this out
and then that's gonna pop them up now
this is unsafe on block but it's her
main combo starter so
and the effects of that are just you
yeah this is your main combo starter
like that's what you're gonna combo off
of and it's something that you can use
like you can put it out on screen zone
behind it or you can put it on screen
and follow it up and there's gonna be
some setups you can do like knock them
down and put it as they're getting up
sure uh then she has this flying attack
move which looks awesome and she can
meter burn it and she actually goes back
around the regular one is unsafe with
the meter booth is actually safe on
block and while it has a gap it's not a
huge gap so it's for the most part safe
you can hear out of the air she's not
like invincible while she's doing it but
it's fast and it's tough and it's kind
of a great like you got the opponent
zone down you want to go in you can go
ahead and go in and kind of catch him
off guard like instantly close the gap
then she has burning desire which is
this hair Witt move it's a great combo
you could end your combos with it on
meter burn it'll actually knock them
down and this is a fully inclusive
wakeup attack so if you meter Burnet
it's safe on block it's full invincible
but the opponent can neutral jump it
mm-hmm so it's not like a foolproof
get-out-of-jail-free card but it's a
great wakeup attack it's a great string
under like maybe you're not sure you
just like a down one and I'm sure it's
gonna hit you can go into this and good
good damage without being punished so
then she has this move which is is like
the coolest thing ever like a disco
party
this is lightens yeah it's this is like
a real live rave and it's like the best
dance that your air move ever made the
move will actually hit in the front and
the ones in the the ones behind her are
active as well so you can use this move
as a wake up attack it even though it's
not invincible if they're jumped like I
just said the way to beat the hair is to
jump so if they're trying to jump that
you can use this this is also one of
your best combo wonders so like
that's a big compliment you can either
burn it and extend it disco party and
you also look awesome when you do it
yeah what's your like what's your
favorite common to do combo to do I mean
should we cover other things first well
can we go over a character power nope
okay all right all right so what a
muscle she's so easy to play oh she also
has an ear - I forgot to mention that
that's kind of important so she hasn't
moving on tremendous mobility so her
character power is actually a beam you
press the circle and you get a
projectile and the longer you hold it
the more damage it does and it can drain
up to half of you see at the bottom for
a literal character power meter so it's
somewhat a Supergirl where you can't
just span the move button you have to
wait for it to recharge now this is for
best combo ender and it's one of her key
zoning tools so the meta here is kind of
do you want to use it in the neutral
like you've conditioned them and then
you use it or do you want to use it at
the end of your combos because the cool
thing is she can special cancel all of
her special moves into her character
power normally right that means you cut
off the end of your cover your special
move in do that's like you can do this
and all you have to do is hold it down
it's very simple like you literally just
do the special move hold down the
character power button and it's gonna
end your combo that's awesome so pretty
much all your big combo wonders we're
gonna end in that you can do it all this
and you can do it in the air yes and you
can do it in the air and and you can
meter burn it and it'll become a Miss so
most of the hits are high so the
opponent will be ducking it if you meter
her in it the last parts of mids so even
if they're ducking they can do some chip
and push them back and it's incredibly
powerful as a zoning tool and it's
incredibly powerful
up close as like to end your special
moves should be super oh wait you want
to see swaggy combos swaggy combos
that's my girl
yeah you'll see she does really really
good damage very easily like she's kind
of a character we're up close she
doesn't have like the best hi-low
mix-ups but if she can keep you away and
she gets a hit she's gonna do really
really good damage say what weaknesses
weaknesses uh like I said she doesn't
really have the best hi-low mix-ups
she's really best from afar I think or
the mid-range her if you were to get up
on her right
yeah if you go if you if you've like
flash Black Canary cat when those
characters have superior mix up so close
I also think kind of her mid-range game
her float speeds not the best and her
four twos a high so there's a lot of
ways to and if she wants to commit to
beating you trying to poke out she just
gets this knocked down so I don't think
her mid-range game is like the best in
the game but I think from afar she is
one of the best I think she also does
have one of the big best wake up so
she's not like incredibly well-rounded
like like a super girl or a Superman but
what she's great at she's really great
at and I don't think she has any like
terrible weaknesses she's very very
solid cool super move super move
oh I mean I forgot one of the mobile
that I absolutely love okay there's
there's a million moves so back to it's
like a little cluster bomb and this is a
tremendous Han tire I honestly think
this is one of the better hit fires so
if it hits do you want me to use the
controller and jump daaamn good actually
gonna back three which is pretty rare
for a big anti-air so that's just back
to let's make yeah that's just back to
and it has a lot of or it has very fast
recovery so it's kind of safe like let's
just say you're kind of playing the
neutral you think they might jump
because that's one of the best things
that you can do you can just throw it
out and if it hits you can easily see
going to a back three and go into a big
like 400 damage anti-air combo nice so
now we want to see her super yeah yes
nice yes so basically I think she's
really in this excel for full screen I
think if you're like playing a match up
where zonings pretty strong she's gonna
do really really well and I think she
has decent tools in the mid-range if she
has to play that too and I think um
she'll probably appeal to both people
that kind of like a little weird like
you know they're gonna find like cross
up strategies and tech like that with
the jump three but she'll also appeal to
like a player like me who just wants it
straightforward like simple character to
play with something you can use the same
combos off like every ender and stuff
like that which definitely appeals to me
I do my best thinking while doing combos
I don't know if you guys know that I do
yeah let's take a look so much some
shaders and shaders other stuff yeah
okay shaders and abilities that's not a
song well you know a 10 Steve yeah all
right we got a Blackfyre sure a lot of
people wanted this it was requested
highly requested and a cool thing you'll
see here is her hair actually changes
including the fire effect if she does
her hair boom which i think is super
super cool the hype is real alright so I
gave her two moves here one is she can
actually meter burn or throw off this I
love the twirling hair and she can
actually choose which direction to throw
them and then she gets a launcher that's
awesome so this actually helps her
mid-range game a lot you know before she
doesn't really get huge damage off of it
it's good space control but now she'll
actually get big big damage can you know
way through yeah but you could yeah but
I didn't want to do it because I might
drop it so thanks for bringing that up
okay Wow sorry bro
he did it I should have shot yourself
never doubt yourself never ask yourself
so the second thing I gave her is a
charge move so like I said the charge
time she can only use her character
power a couple times for us you can see
it recharging there right
I knew this move allows her to recharge
it very quickly so if you're playing
kind of a keep out match and you're
really using it a lot go ahead and
recharge it and the opponent's gonna
have to go in or let you recharge it and
you can see that it's very very quick to
reach out and sure is well so that's our
black fire loadout nice so let's go and
do one more I made just one more all
right I really like this color that's
cool all right so I gave her a airflow
move okay and then you can actually
control where she floats and you can
drop down immediately if you want and
this is just gonna extend her air moves
like you know you could float behind
them accidentally did it I gave it away
so this replaces her burning desire hair
move with a ground pound but there's
something unique about it she can
actually charge it float in the air for
a minute
and then come down she could meet her
burn at taking a combo and the coolest
thing is while she's holding it she can
actually float out of it oh hi eek nice
she can even float out of it and go to
this move which is why I put them
together in the slowdown this is my air
mobility loadout oh yeah air boom my air
mobility loadout so while you lose
you're a really fantastic safe on block
wakeup move you get a combo extender and
better air mobility with these fake outs
and I love the shower pound is different
distances it is not it's only this
distance that's all there is to it cool
love it yeah yeah I do I actually do go
first you go first cuz I usually go
first and then you make fun of me okay
yeah all right so you go